Nashville famous for putting on great
shows the big events in Music City today
though not on stage at the Ryman but in
the sky above it David beg no is at the
Grand Ole Opry where some famous names
and entertainment are gathered to watch
these stellar event David good morning
good morning from the stage of the Grand
Ole Opry the show that made country
music famous is about to eclipse itself
with something that is going to blend
science and music in fact last night
here on the stage performers had a heck
of a show which is exceptionally rare on
a Sunday night and it was all about the
Eclipse and they brought in some pretty
big names in music city even the Eclipse
comes with a soundtrack
some of country music's biggest names
turned out Sunday on country music's
biggest stage assuring in a celestial
celebration more than 38 years in the
making
I'm looking for my glasses hang on
[Applause]
[Music]
today's impending party in the sky is
turning rock stars into stargazers you
can't see anything when you look up at
the Sun yeah it all comes in wow Google
this so many times I've googled when it
doesn't happen you know what exactly is
happening it's not just a reason to
party it's something's it's something
that's really big in science that that
that happens so rarely we've always just
been fans of science and rather work for
sky and a society to Scott Bolden says
the connection between music and science
is not very complicated
it's the same equations that can
describe what happens when I pluck a
guitar string as what's happening in the
interior of Jupiter it's all harmony
it's all harmonics resonances all of
nature's vibration
[Music]
that sounds vibrating from downtown
Nashville don't require much scientific
theory Nashville is the largest city in
the country that is in the direct path
of the solar eclipse this is what we
call a new moon that's on steroids
Tom Parsons is an astrologist who says
there is an emotional aspect to all of
this we could have like a rebirth or
reboot of our lives at this particular
time so this is the time to take action
and assert yourself and go after the
objectives and goals that you want to
accomplish
Katie lagers using today to say I do she
and her fiance Dan will celebrate one of
the brightest moments of their lives
under the darkness of totality I'm just
excited to finally be able to start our
life together and I think it's it's very
neat that we do get to share such a big
day with the city that I love so much
people are traveling from all over the
place to different places in the u.s.
just to follow this and I think we're so
lucky that we ended up like right in the
middle of it hey congratulations you two
back here at the Opry we've got our
drone up in the air all of this cement
on this Opry property is expected to be
filled with people we're told as many as
90,000 folks have driven in already got
in a hotel room up early this morning
ready to stare at the sky Gale every
party in the South you know has a menu
and on the menu today the moon pie we
had guests that David very nice nicely
done nicely nicely what a great day to
have a wedding yeah or it turns totally
dark you'll always remember that those
two thank you David